joël regnault vit ses dernières heures
comme maire de plaisir ce jeudi soir
conseil municipal extraordinaire
les 39 conseillers municipaux plaisir
roi vont se réunir pour élire un nouveau
maire eh bien j'ai souhaité tout
simplement comme dans une entreprise
anticipées ce passage de relais c'est
important parce que on ne peut plus
prendre de risques avec les
collectivités je vais rester au conseil
municipal pour les apps pour les aider
les accompagner tant que faire se peut
jusqu'en mars 2014 préparer avec eux la
campagne électorale je ne serai pas sur
l'a10 de mars 2014 joël regnault passe
la main à son adjointe à la culture
joséphine coleman d'hergé élu à la ville
de plaisir depuis 2001 elle est investie
depuis 30 ans dans le milieu associatif
et artistique du côté de l'opposition le
départ de joël regnault s'explique pour
eux la campagne des municipales est
lancée aujourd'hui pour nombre de
plaisir oit le compte n'y est pas et que
donc les habitants attendent quelque
chose de plus mais je pense que la
majorité en a déjà conscience et donc
d'une certaine façon moi je pars du
principe qu aujourd'hui 18 mois avant
mars 2014 eh bien on est rentré en
campagne municipale je me dis que somme
toute c'est assez assez logique même
cosmen vergès donc son adjointe à la
culture qui va lui lui succéder je
trouve a été beaucoup mis en avant
depuis un peu plus d'un an
ça s'est vu notamment au moment de la
campagne sur les sénatoriales à l'été
sixième sur la liste de gérard larcher
une passation de pouvoir entre un maire
et un adjoint cela n'est pas rare
récemment le cas s'est présenté à la
verrière et à magny les hameaux où
respectivement pierre sellal cours et
jacno lloze ont quitté leur fauteuil de
maire avant la fin de leur mandat